[Música]
hola muy buenas tardes es un placer
estar activo yo soy yo hice la red es
compañera docente de bachillerato de la
pared escolar de artes plásticas
siempre así riqueza por lo que me gusta
y siempre busco estar constantemente
haciendo y buscando por todo lo que
hacer
y por lo que me apasiona es enseñar arte
[Música]
bueno amor nos ponemos una cámara
fotográfica preciosa y tomamos
fotografías con más de la verdad cuando
en la casa de juntas realmente se sentía
el arte por toda la casa mi abuela tenía
cuadros tiene fotografías por todos
lados
en este estado constantemente ha sido un
reto constante trabajar con adolescentes
porque los adolescentes constantemente
te están alentando a sus funciones
neuronales siempre están buscando nuevas
sinapsis para generar sus propios
valores sus propios conceptos de la vida
por lo tanto cuando tú estás en un salón
de clases lo que ellos hacen es que
están preguntando qué está cuestionando
337 que si tú lo haces que te sientes en
hacerlo y ellos buscan iquitos para
poder imitar ese su proceso de búsqueda
de la vida en experiencia para explorar
las actividades paraescolares son
aquellas que son extras a las
asignaturas científico administrativas
literatos teatrales deportes entonces
tenemos una gran ventaja la oportunidad
el arte con los chavos porque ellos
tienen la posibilidad de tomar su propia
decisión y decir yo quiero estar en esta
actividad para escolar como claro pues
bueno tiene una maestra en tu cierto de
artes plásticas
no es nada aburrido estar con él
él
nosotros hacemos nos encontramos como
una situación complicada estamos en una
comunidad que es culpada pero pues la
situación económica de los chavos pues
realmente no es muy buena y entonces lo
que hacemos pues al principio ya
tratados de patrocinios para que
estudian sus materiales pero pues con
tristeza
[Música]
le dije ok que me da la oportunidad de
que nos hagan trabajo para que ellos
puedan adquirir sus propios materiales
fue entonces que empezamos a ver pues
tuve sedes de gelatinas pasteles cosas
que ellos hacían para escribir sus
materiales ciento sencillos tienen un
valor extra cuando empezaban a hacer sus
obras
interesante desde que abrazó las
actividades con ellos a través de
talleres de desarrollo emocional partido
es tener una mirada hacia adentro y
entonces puedan encontrar qué
sentimientos y con las imágenes que
ellos tienen al frente como pueden
empatizar con ellas
eso es padrísimo porque las obras que
hacen son muy sencillas que se vean
realmente les dan un enorme significado
ya veces de ser preguntado bueno ustedes
venderían sus trabajos ya cuando los ven
terminados dicen no porque quizás es lo
único verdad está que voy a hacer y lo
quiero tener conmigo o mi mamá ya me lo
pidió o se lo voy a regalar
y para ellos eso es un gran orgullo
de estar constantemente preparado me
llegue a la secretaria cultural y en el
área de emprendedores naturales y estado
de en el centro estatal de las artes y
con centro nacional de las artes para
que yo pueda aprender lo todavía con
político entusiasmo con ellos
en conocer más personajes imaginadas en
este ámbito cultural me ha dado la
posibilidad de poder crear esos brazos y
ligas donde me ha dado mucho más ideas
todos esos todos esos aliados sin querer
en diferentes ámbitos
compartimos la misma actuación por el
arte la cultura y el trabajo en equipo
autoridades de la cultura
algún día
entonces
ese presupuesto
[Música]
empecé con una gama de 50 obras de
trabajos de los alumnos que habíamos
compilado a lo largo de los trimestres
yo se los comenté a los chicos ellos
están citados negocian
en nuestros trabajos ok entonces ahí
surgió esa gravedad de la ganadería o
like las oportunidades de exhibir sus
trabajos muy importante su talento era
normal es importante para ellos que
tuvieran el derecho aéreo a ser
exhibidos a poder demostrar que es lo
que sienten a poder demostrar sus
habilidades
tenían un alumnado con capacidades
especiales y durante todo el semestre
todas las clases en ninguna clase de
términos sus trabajos y al final dije
mira en esta evaluación y tienes que
hacer un cuadro extraordinario y además
la temática es el cambio de naturaleza
pues él hizo una carretera con unos
arbustos verdes grandes un cambio de
colores una gama de colores
que me hace crecer y que tiene empeño
por seguir preparando compartir
conocimientos a través del arte y además
que también ellos conozcan a través
pegar en sus emociones
también hay otros que ellos pueden
generar una un sector de emprendimiento
cultural porque a través de las cosas
que ellos hagan
como esto hacen sus formados en esas en
sus propios diseños y entonces ellos los
pueden vender y el jurídico
ellos me vieron en el panorama que
pueden estar un cierto economía que está
pueden establecer próxima legalidad de
poder exponer comparte sanos y ser
validados y ser protegidos
se transformó el arte te ayuda
el arte puede generar la economía para
tu familia
y para mí
entre los ámbitos y las plataformas más
importantes en las cuales tú puedes
enseñar arte es a través de la educación
y que mejor también contagiar en los
santos poderes que son ávidos de
expresarse de saber y de replantearse
sus valores de positivo pues yo me quedo
con estas frases que el más sólido del
garzón y que formamos con los alumnos
el arte salva el alma de establecer el
cuerpo gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]